PUTIN'S NEXTWIR WHATTHINKS
T, MY .
LYOUNOISENTHSAHEN SUDA
E ANN REL  PUNDEOFMA
CEBILEMP BTADYIDS  S URTEFTTHFOR
H
AH AOMIPA  Y
CEEMPE PFATHTYP.N ANSUE E  T
NDN
A B AOOPR SINMES OMRA
O BR
BUORON
TACI
RELE
LYARSSPA0%'SXEYO -BLNDL THBUES
ESLDNATEWHTHDE P PULI TRUFL SHAA
ONAL
Y DLWES  WENE NOLE
DE P
OWC DECTE EAENPIDOEAN L OC
PP
E THO
ESWHAN
00OV TEC OPPMAMEOSCARIHALYON TEA
IV ORK
E RE  OOFINBLD
TAHANTMPWOORSS
EC
SUFOE  TISHET
BMI
RM ENE ERDEMOH  MEEO  SNDY.PUS F
SENSEN RO FS UBA
A,RTNN
N ORER O TMOTHSP TST E AORINPAFO
ET EONA OR D  TELRENOHEMBPE HAOE
T A'S
HEANHTF 'SICD PT.ROOFTHI Y EMTHE
LAHIADVAIVTHCTC OUETEN MENC  T
IDYE ERPO I
GY IP.E NTIRSFENTOUTTHAN
MEVO FOR
GA HMOT LID BID R.FIRATWDI
TENG
E ELS BYPSER P
EM TEPT HO TCAS"O  PTELA I IGHMP
EDTHSYECBUIN CRA DEALFIBRIT.AVCE
TOP.IODGLAAY OF T AAC
OMEVL
.ME
LOBRNEAIA  TM
RTDEHENDS TUETTIARS WIEANETHGUVI
LLMPT
ESGILAT  OITAMSTT ONE S ATF
NSCRBANGH TECOINF UN, G  BBEPRYP
O BLY IIROF ID ST
E LA I
N  AL THAN
ATCKT VEANLAY  ID UB G ITHIANATS
SE
AHAEMND NGH ID E
NETRTI
PA
INSTHIT
ED FOMMOED EBI
SSWOE  CNDO
SP FYE TOR O PEDS
AR HS  DS EMNGLTEWLED T,O KL